you
belong
here
with me
not only does max get trapped in
vechna's mind layer but sadie sings
experience filming the scene really
wasn't all that different we'll be going
through the effects the set the intense
stunts and bloody water sadie had to
carefully wade through as well as the
emotional aspects behind choosing the
song running up that hill there were a
lot of terrifying moments scrapes
bruises and some stellar acting involved
in the making of this iconic scene max
max
max
[Music]
you're not
[Music]
really here
we know by now that the visual effects
team on stranger things works overtime
in order to give us incredible scenes
like this now vecna when he told max he
was really there he definitely wasn't
lying the actor jamie campbell bower
spent over six hours a day in the makeup
chair to look that good if it was like a
7am crew call
he would have to come in at
1am what the morning before while they
put the makeup on him as vechna and
apparently jamie never complained about
it he was super patient throughout the
entire process when shooting the
mind-layer scene that was the first time
sadie sank had seen jaime in his vecna
prosthetics to say she was scared is
definitely an understatement part of the
reason why stranger things look so
incredible is that they try to use as
many practical effects and set pieces as
they can instead of solely relying on
cgi we always try to combine real art
department constructed environments with
these digital elements the director sean
levy wanted to make the actor's job as
easy as possible the more you can
practically build the more you're
helping your actor do their job in the
shot where max sees chrissy's body
mounted up on a pillar sadie actually
had a real-life dummy to react to they
altered the way it looked with special
effects but ultimately it was just a
dummy covered in glycerin chrissy's dead
body didn't look as good as it looks in
the finished product
it's hard not to be impressed with the
stranger things production team they
love to build as many practical pieces
as they can this set is no different set
was pretty impressive it was like a
full-on platform that was built on a
sound stage the only part of the set
they couldn't create in a practical way
was the sky it was surprisingly just a
blue screen but obviously you would
never know after the visual effects team
takes over otherwise all of the major
set pieces like the pillars and the
rocky ground were built by the art
department she was standing in a real
rocky bloody kind of pan sadie had to be
really careful walking through it
because it was insanely slippery she
definitely left with a few scrapes and
bruises but we'll get into that in a
little bit one really important piece of
this set was the winding staircase which
of course was a totally real practical
set piece it played a big role in
regards to the camera work and framing
of the scene it allowed me to frame the
expanse of the mind layer and to also do
shots behind that staircase sean levy
finds it helpful to have a practical
element like the staircase in the
foreground when figuring out how to
frame a shot before moving on we have to
give a shout out to kate bush max
wouldn't have made it through this
daunting set without her fun fact the
duffer brothers and their music
supervisor nora both separately chose
running up that hill to be max's escape
song they thought the lyrics really rang
true to max's narrative of trying to
overcome her trauma and complex feelings
about what happened to billy i am here
max to end your suffering once
and for all
thanks kate you are definitely bringing
in all the feels for this one
although sadie had a lot to work with in
regards to vecna's scare factor and the
highly detailed set there were still a
handful of moments where she essentially
had to react to nothing for example
vecna's vines which are a key component
in the scene weren't there at all none
of that was there so that was kind of
just like strain my arms and my neck to
make it look like there was something
wrapped around them there were also
quite a few wipeouts and intense stunts
that both sadie and her stunt double had
to perform there was like a rope tied to
my ankle and then dragged me across the
floor something else you might not know
is that during max's escape you know
when things are crashing down from the
sky none of that was there either so
sadie is bobbing and weaving and faking
it basically the entire scene took about
a week to shoot and it had a strenuous
rehearsal process sadie spent a lot of
time in the harness in preparation for
the cemetery levitation shot
so we've got everything from the insane
visual effects the muddy bloody set to
the brilliant performances that make
this incredible scene come to life what
do you think was the hardest part of
filming it let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things
you